chérie je voulais absolument vous
montrer aussi le message très touchant
dacca taux pret où elle a publié ce
matin agathe notre notre collègue à
notre ami un message sur instagram elle
a révélé être atteinte d'un cancer
elle a dit je dois vous dire quelque
chose j'ai un cancer un lymphome
exactement je suis en chimiothérapie
depuis mi décembre et pendant encore
trois mois je suis souvent à l'hôpital
je suis très fatigué je perds mes
cheveux j'ai un cathéter que je déteste
placer son ma peau mais tout va bien
tout va bien je me repose je ne vais pas
mourir je répond très bien aux
traitements
j'avais juste besoin d'arrêter de mentir
ou tout du moins d'arrêter de faire
semblant ici devant vous tous les jours
donc vous voulez je vous la voulez vous
dire qu'on était enfin j'étais moi au
courant depuis plusieurs mois bien sûr
de ce qui arrive et agathe qu'on est
tous là bien sûr pour la soutenir que
elle va bien le sera avec nous jeudi
dans balances ton post est que voilà
elle a été très bien pris en charge
elle voulait absolument en parler parce
que c'est vrai qu'elle en avait marre de
mentir en plus c'est la voilà la vdl
perd ses cheveux donc est là voilà elles
voulaient pas que les gens se demandent
pourquoi
voilà la moins de cheveux pourquoi elle
met des cols roulés parce que c'est vrai
qu'elles elles doivent être des coloris
parce que d'un cathéter voilà qu'elle a
donc elle avait la main et marc de
mentir et c'est vrai voilà elle est
toujours avec nous bien sûr on la
soutient à fond toute l'équipe et vous
le savez des pmp c'est une famille et
elle fait plus que partie de la famille
et voilà donc on lui fait de gros bisous
et bien entendu on étouffe voilà sumbe
dans cette dure épreuve qu'elle traverse
et j'espère que de faire de l'antenne
avec nous d'être avec nous dans btp ça
lui fait du bien en tout cas elle
voulait absolument continuer l'antenne
voilà je vous le redis
voilà on fait des gros bisous vous je
sais qu'il y en a plein qui ne le
savaient pas ici vous l'avez appris
voilà mais elle voulait absolument pas
ce qu'elle voulait pas en parler mais
les dix voix la soutiennent elle a
craqué elle a dit voilà j'ai envie de le
dire et alors moi je suis très j'ai été
vraiment stupéfaite en apprenant la
nouvelle ce matin je ne savais pas je la
trouve particulièrement courageux je
vais envoyer un sms pour lui dire
justement comment je la trouvais
courageuse je pense que ça doit lui
faire du bien d'en parler mais qu'est ce
que cela est difficile de combattre la
maladie en silence de faire semblant
pendant des mois et le simple fait d'en
avoir parlé permet aussi à d'autres de
faire face à la maladie bravo à elle en
tout cas pour son courage et message il
est bouleversant je n'étais pas du tout
au courant et je les trouvais
bouleversant de sincérité dans ses mots
une sorte de de pudeur qui transparaît à
travers ce qu'elle a écrit voilà je vous
souhaite de tout coeur à 1 un bon
rétablissement on est vraiment avec elle
et j'ai senti dans ses mots une force et
c'est cette force qui va la faire on lui
fait de gros bisous langues et toute
l'équipe merci à vous devez vous avez
tous mis des mots sur les réseaux
sociaux et je pense que ça l'à beaucoup
touché
en tout cas merci